excusez-moi vous avez une machine à
Étienne
j'espère qu'elle est pas fixée au mur
quoi rien ça devrait être assez facile
je fais un petit trou
et je remercie
non c'est pas bon
pourtant
qu'est-ce que tu fabriques là rien rien
du tout vous inquiétez pas tout tout le
monde tout va bien c'est juste que j'ai
oublié mon code
s'il vous plaît monsieur laissez-moi
vous dépouiller espèce de ta chien
de ma vie j'aimerais regarder un bon
souvenir un bon souvenir tu mets le
bande-son dans ma boutique
pour info je suis un scientifique
j'étais maintenant aussi je vous dis
quelque chose avec je travaillais là-bas
avant j'étais plutôt séduisante
j'ai eu un petit accident
et maintenant regardez-moi
pour commencer je vous ai même pas volé
je vous rappelle que cette machine
Étienne n'est même pas à vous elle
appartient à la banque c'est eux les
vrais criminels toi c'est toi qui me
braques là vous savez cette émission
impossible de trouver un vrai boulot
dans mon état alors je me suis tourné
vers le crime de machine à Étienne dis
quoi le M ça veut déjà dire machine